marauding space aliens and their ilk
aren't the true dangers that lurk within
your favorite video games what you
really need to be worried about our
blood clots a lack of movements and a
vulnerability to game and do psychosis
it might look like you're just sitting
there on your couch but the reality of
what your body and mind are going
through is pretty intense
there have been many unfortunate gamers
who have paid for their passion here are
a few heartbreaking stories to remind us
that video games can be pretty serious
business the berserk heart attack it may
not look like much but berserk is one of
the earliest known examples of a video
game ending in actual death in April of
1982 an 18 year old named Peter Bukowski
landed a couple of high scores on a
berserk arcade cabinet before collapsing
from a heart attack doctors later found
out that he had a compromised
cardiovascular system which was agitated
beyond repair by the game an October
1982 article in videogames magazine site
studies that used pong to measure
physiological reactions to videogame
induced stress dating as far as 1977 the
body's physical reaction to on-screen
events was found to be pretty
significant the EverQuest suicide
EverQuest affectionately called ever
crack or never rest by its many
dedicated fans is an online game known
for drawing in easily addicted gamers
the draw is so intense that it's well
known to break apart relationships and
cause people to ignore real-life
responsibilities Shawn Wooley took his
EverQuest passion to the extreme in 2002
quitting his job to play full-time after
he ignored a Thanksgiving invitation
from his family his loved ones found
wooly dead in front of his computer from
a self-inflicted gunshot wound with
EverQuest still running Woolley took his
own life for unknown reasons but
evidence suggested that it may have been
related to a troubled in-game
relationship Sean's mother later accused
the publisher of intentionally harming
her son I didn't know the game was
written to get him in there to draw him
in there and to keep him in there so
that they could make money
the legend of mir3 stabbing its another
online gaming incident with tragic
real-life ramifications legend of mere
players q Cheng Wei and Zhu K Yan
jointly earned a very rare very virtual
Dragon sabre sword in 2005 but Jue
decided to sell the sword on e-bay
without Q's consent earning around 870
dollars for the sale the two players
couldn't come to a reasonable agreement
as to proper dispersal of payment for
the sword so q stabs you to death in his
sleep q was sentenced to life in prison
but will be eligible for parole in 2020
the FarmVille murder sadly even
farmville can turn evil in the wrong
hands Alexandra Tobias a 22 year old
mother was so addicted to the game that
she shook her three-month-old son to
death because his crying interrupted her
playing
Tobias received a 50-year prison
sentence for her actions in 2011 at one
point she allegedly confessed to a
fellow inmate that she hid her baby's
head against the computer monitor in the
process of trying to shake him into
silence unfortunately it's not all that
uncommon for children to suffer while
parents game the world of warcraft
murder the story of Rebecca colleen
kristy offers a worst case scenario when
it comes to game addiction Kristy spent
such an inordinate amount of time
playing Warcraft that she allowed her
three-year-old daughter to starve to
death
prosecutors found that Kristi had just
engaged in a non-stop 15 hour warcraft
session prior to finally calling 911 who
was found unresponsive she was
subsequently sentenced to 25 years in
prison for the crime of neglect on the
other hand some parents go above and
beyond for their kids as we see next
water intoxication for a Nintendo Wii
in 2007 the Nintendo Wii was still hard
to get in the US so the Sacramento based
radio station KD & E decided to run a
contest giving one of the consoles away
the challenge drink a huge amount of
water without urinating and whoever went
last won the Nintendo system
unfortunately water intoxication can be
fatal and
contestant Jennifer Strange collapsed
and died after failing to win the prize
for her children the station fired 10
employees and lost a 16 million dollar
lawsuit for the juvenile stunts the
ingress incident a mobile app that
requires you to get up and move around
seems like a great idea until that app
sends you directly into traffic
Gabriel Leal was an unfortunate casualty
of truly mobile gaming while playing
ingress in 2014 the 16 year old
brazilian teen lost track of his
surroundings while rushing to a portal
in the game and was killed by an
oncoming bus while ingress has built-in
limits to prevent certain unsafe
behaviors there was nothing to stop and
absorbed an enthusiastic kid from
walking into a busy street the limits
also didn't help frank maxwell a 48 year
old father who drowned near a pier in
Ireland while playing the game in 2015
the slender stabbing and arson slender
the arrival didn't directly kill anyone
but an obsession with its main baddie
influenced a few impressionable young
girls to do some insidious things in May
of 2014 two twelve-year-old girls from
Cincinnati Ohio stabbed their classmate
19 times believing that they had to
murder someone in order to appease the
mythical villain Slenderman just as
disturbing is the case of a 14 year old
girl who set her family's Florida home
on fire with her mother and younger
brother still inside fortunately no one
was harmed the girl was also obsessed
with Slender Man lore and reportedly
started the fire in order to gain his
favour the deadly Diablo 3 halo
Starcraft and Warcraft marathons gamers
please note you have to get up and move
around sometimes because the list of
deaths from sitting on your butt and
twiddling your thumbs just keeps growing
in 2012 an 18 year old named Chuang died
in an internet cafe in Taiwan after 40
continuous hours of Diablo 3 the second
marathon game-related death in Taiwan
that year in 2011 England's Chris
Stannah fourth died from deep vein
thrombosis after playing 12 hours of
Halo in 2005 lease on salt died in
South Korea after 50 hours of StarCraft
the list doesn't end there and it goes
on quite a while moral of the story
don't take extended gameplay lightly
even when you're in the thick of the
action remember that the pause button
exists take a break stand up get some
water and move around every once in a
while it'll be there when you get back
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
you